Luxembourg is the only country in the
world whose Prime Minister is openly gay
we are talking about one of the most
tolerant open-minded societies on the
planet in fact they have a population of
around 500,000 inhabitants and 40% of
them are immigrants in other words
Luxembourg is the smallest country in
the European Union Marta the one with
the biggest share of immigrants
nonetheless what made Luxembourg famous
can be summarized in just one word and
that word is money yes dear viewer the
Grand Duchy of Luxembourg is one of the
three wealthiest countries on earth here
the minimum wage is around 2,000 euros a
month no that's not average wage that's
the minimum wage the normal wage in
Luxembourg five thousand euros a month
for comparison Luxembourgish people have
a GDP per capita twice as big as that of
Australians or the Danes
alright alright but just hold on for a
second because there is a little trick
in this figure you see almost half of
the workers in this country actually
live outside of it every day around
160,000 people commute to this country
and then go back to their homes in
Germany France or Belgium in other words
they create wealth in the country but
they don't live there this is why when
we divide Luxembourg's GDP among their
population we get such an enormous
number
but even with these statistical
deviations no one can deny that
Luxembourg is kind of a country for
millionaires and this explains why its
capital Luxembourg City is among the
cities in the world with the highest
quality of life many of you might think
that this can all be explained because
Luxembourg is a fiscal Haven but the
truth is that other countries like Malta
and Cyprus also have low taxes but they
are not even half as rich as Luxembourg
so the big question here is what does
Luxembourg have that makes them so
incredibly wealthy what did they do in
this country to enjoy such a fantastic
quality of life
today well we are going to answer that
very question but before we do let's
take a look back at the history the keys
of Steel by the year 1815 the Grand
Duchy of Luxembourg became an
independent country and I say
independence because none of its
neighbors really recognized its
independence France and Prussia what
Germany used to be back then fought for
control of the Duchy on several
occasions
in fact despite their government's
desire for independence the territory of
Luxembourg was owned by King William the
third of the Netherlands during these
years Luxembourg was far from being a
wealthy country most of its citizens
survived thanks to agriculture and iron
mining back then one in every five
people from Luxembourg was emigrating to
America nonetheless living between two
rival countries like France and Prussia
had its advantages too you see during
this time Germany didn't exist as a
country instead there were a lot of
Republic's kingdoms and duchies united
under a Confederation
if you want to know what a confederation
is well click on this video the truth is
all the German states traded among
themselves that basically created a
special free trade zone which they
called the sovereign
alright so in 1942 Luxembourg became a
member of this sovereign and since that
point history well it would never be the
same again as I said before poor
Luxembourg was based on two main
industries agriculture and iron mining
and remember here these are the times of
the Industrial Revolution steel was
needed for well basically everything it
was used in everything from machines to
buildings and Luxembourgish citizens
well they were sitting on top of a pile
of iron but not only that we're talking
about a tiny country placed in the
intersection between France Germany and
Belgium in other words it was the
perfect points have a railroad so they
could send the iron to all three
countries all the sudden Luxembourg
became ground zero for all of these
trade routes as well as one of the
biggest steel providers on the planet in
fact many of those New York skyscrapers
were built with beams made in this
country
this is why the biggest steel companies
are Luxembourgish the biggest of them
all
ArcelorMittal is one that you might have
even heard about in financial newspapers
in other words in just a few decades
luxembourg got to the same level as its
neighbors but still it was not the
economic BM off that it is today they
still needed a special sauce and while
that special sauce was this 1929 this is
the year when luxembourg passed the
holding law passed wait just a minute
here because you might now be wondering
well what's corporate holding all about
well let's take coca-cola as an example
on the one hand coca-cola is a beverage
brand but on the other hand there is the
coca-cola company this is a big
conglomerate that contains other
companies like Fanta Schweppes or Coca
Cola the beverage brand itself
okay so this big conglomerate is called
a Holding Corporation and the companies
inside it are called subsidiary
companies these subsidiaries can be in
different countries and other guys who
produce and distribute the drinks
however the role of the holding company
is mainly to manage the property of
these other subsidiary companies all
right so this 1929 law it offered
amazingly good tax conditions to those
holding companies basically they paid
around 1% tax
take these were the 1930s and back then
there weren't as many holding companies
as there are today just remember that
those were the years when coca-cola was
starting to expand to other markets so
Luxembourg was doing great but they
still weren't the giant that they are
today in other words Luxembourg was
growing but not that much more than
other countries
nonetheless these 70s were the times
when American companies conquered the
European and Asian markets that finally
had some money to spend on consumer
goods during these years many of the big
corporations we know today were born in
other words a lot of holding sprang up
and their profits came from all around
the planet so where did they decide to
set up their headquarters well since
they could choose anywhere they wanted
to they went to the places with the best
fiscal conditions and Luxembourg had
everything they wanted and a whole lot
more you see by the 1960s in the 1970s
the country already had a big banking
industry the best lawyers accountants
and economists were living there ready
to help those big companies in order to
take advantage of those business
friendly laws and this is how this
little country got into their silver
decades
yes do you believe what you see the
economy of Luxembourg became 2 times
bigger in less than 6 years compared to
this China or Singapore's growth rate
it's kind of a joke
and yes you had that right I did say
before silver decade because all of this
growth was nothing compared to what was
to come
think about it we are already talking
about the 2000s the age of the online
business boom these brand new corporate
juggernauts operated all over the world
had dozens of subsidiary companies in
every country and not concentrated in
any specific location because they sold
everywhere
in other words these tech companies were
made to love Luxembourg so if you
thought this country was already
astoundingly rich and could have grown
more well do think twice
it's amazing isn't it I don't know if
you noticed this but in just five years
Luxembourg's GDP per capita went from
fifty thousand US dollars which is
already a lot to over 100 thousand
dollars when you live in the country
with a GDP per capita of over a hundred
thousand dollars well you can fill your
swimming pool with champagne
in fact the Audi a3 is the third
best-selling car in Luxembourg
and yes well I probably do know what
you're thinking right now you think that
this country has made its fortune by
helping companies avoid paying their
taxes right well the answer it's a
little bit more complicated than that
you see the fact that a holding
Corporation is located in Luxembourg
does not mean that its subsidiary
companies don't pay taxes elsewhere for
instance Amazon has its headquarters in
Luxembourg nonetheless it's British
subsidiary that is the company that
sells products and managers logistics in
this country still has to pay taxes in
the UK or at least that is the theory in
fact the reality is way different luxe
leaks so let's get back to our Amazon
example as we said the profits of his
British subsidiary are taxed in the UK
right
well the question that then comes up is
what if they don't have any profits
whatsoever imagine that right after they
pay taxes Amazon UK gets a big loan a
big loan with a really high interest
rate so high in fact that the company it
takes losses and who lends them that
money exactly well of course that would
be Amazon holdings in Luxembourg this
weight these subsidiary companies have
almost no profits one way or another
they manage to send their money to the
Luxembourg branch and as we said before
in Luxembourg taxes are really low for
companies of course all of this is
perfectly legal but in 2009 during the
financial crisis the American government
realized the huge amount of money they
were losing with all of these big
companies moving overseas that's why
today I'm announcing a set of proposals
to crackdown on illegal overseas tax
evasion closed loopholes and make it
more profitable for companies to create
jobs here in the United States since
then other governments have also
followed in obamas steps
now don't forget Luxembourg is one of
the European Union's founding members
this means the other club members were
angry and willing to lay on a lot of
political pressure but the biggest
crisis for this country came in the year
2014 this was the time when a group of
accountants released a ton of private
data from these big corporations
thanks to the so called Lux leaks we
could all see the tax evasion strategies
employed by thousands of different
companies now do you know what I told
you about loans between different
subsidiary companies within a holding
well here is another way of improving
the deal you see all these big companies
have big consulting firms so they can
help them with their accounting
consulting firms like
PricewaterhouseCoopers with a big
customer portfolio in Luxembourg there
enough power to sit down with the Prime
Minister back then jean-claude Juncker
and arrange a special tax deal on
current spotlight after Luxembourg Tax
revelations the leaked documents
demonstrate tax arrangements negotiated
by PricewaterhouseCoopers as you can
imagine the release of the lux leaks was
a total GameChanger
in fact this year 2017 Luxembourg passed
a brand-new fiscal reform and probably
many of these arrangements aren't going
to have to change but hold on just a
minute here because this doesn't mean
that Luxembourg is going to stop being a
rich place in fact the opposite is
probably true
despite this political turbulence the
country grew at a rate of 4.2% last year
this is way faster than almost any other
country in Europe having so many savings
Luxembourg has invested in many other
industries now of course they have steel
they have their banks and they also have
space Luxembourg's bet on space industry
shows early signs of success yep you
heard that right in fact Luxembourg in
the United States are the first
countries to pass laws regulating space
mining and this tiny country is expected
to become the Silicon Valley of the
aerospace industry this explains partly
some of the details of the 2017 fiscal
reform of course the governments of
Luxembourg doesn't want to help big
corporations avoid taxes at least this
is what they say officially instead they
have reduced taxes for smaller companies
and are actively trying to improve
conditions in order to encourage more
tech startups but this is a subject for
another video
now the question for you is do you think
we're gonna see another moment of
skyrocketing growth in Luxembourg's
economy
well this country truly become a world
leader in the aerospace industry well
please leave your answer in the comment
section below we'd love to hear from you
meanwhile if you want to know more about
a super wealthy country click on this
video to hear more about guitar and also
do not forget to visit our friends at
the reconsider Media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine and don't forget that we
publish brand new videos every week on
Mondays and Thursday so hit that
subscribe button and give us a thumbs up
and as always I'll see you next time
and if you want to learn more about
politics and hear more of my lovely
voice don't forget to check out the
reconsider podcast at reconsider
Mediacom we consider is a podcast that
challenges you to reconsider your views
by providing context but we don't do the
thinking for you